hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his sermon number nine upon
forgiveness of injuries Joseph Butler is
going to set out for us some of the
problematic aspects of the retaliation
that is the natural operation and aim of
the feeling passion emotion however you
want to Define it of anger which
sometimes he calls resentment he goes
back and forth between the two of these
and he tells us listen anger is a
passion or a desire an affectation which
has been implanted in human nature by
God he tells us that in sermon number
eight and he reiterates that in sermon
number nine so that would lead some
people to say oh well then it's
perfectly fine to respond and to indulge
yourself in anger and Butler wants to
caution us against that now as we saw in
sermon number eight anger does in fact
have some legitimate ends whether it's
the Hasty or sudden anger or the settled
or deliberate anger of self-defense
protecting ourselves also protecting
other people and then preventing or
punishing injury there by not just
helping ourselves and those close to us
but Society in general so people get
angry at other people doing what they're
not supposed to do injury for Joseph
Butler means more than just simply
harming somebody there's a sense of
wrongdoing
involved and anger as he's going to
point out we should remind ourselves of
this aims at imposing something bad on
the person who is its Target or object
so you get angry at somebody by
retaliating you're not doing something
good to them you may they say oh it's
for their good or it's for the good of
society but really the the actual means
is to do something bad you yell at them
you punch him in the nose you take away
a privilege and ground them you do
whatever it is
if they view it as a good thing then
it's a pretty unsuccessful Act of
retaliation
now Butler says that we can have
wrong-headed ideas about how this ought
to work he talks about custom and false
honor which are on the side of
retaliation and revenge when the
resentment is natural and just but you
know that tends to go a little bit too
far and he says that I'm not going to
examine what's alleged in favor of it
from the tyranny of custom and false
honor but only to consider the nature
and reason of the thing itself so we're
going to put aside
culture and societal expectations and
having grown up in a family of shouters
or whatever it's going to be where you
got wrong-headed ideas about retaliation
and anger we're just going to look at it
in in a more Broad
cross-cultural and what he's calling
natural sense
so one of the first problems that he
signals with retaliation and anger is a
tendency to produce more anger as a
result and I think that this is
completely dead on sometimes you see
people who are talking about anger in
philosophy like Aristotle for example
saying that we don't get angry at those
who are angry at us because you know we
assume that what they're they're doing
is the right thing and you know that
does not track our human experience at
all whereas Butler I think really does
he says
malice or resentment towards any person
has a tendency to beget the same passion
in him who is the object of it so person
a does something to person B person B
now gets angry at person a retaliates
out of that now person a is also angry
at person B for having gotten angry at
them in the first place so now we've got
more anger that has been created we have
a kind of surplus right it has
replicated itself within the
relationship and he says this again
increases in the other it is of the very
nature of this Vice to propagate itself
not only by way of example which it does
in common with other devices so you know
we see other people getting angry we're
like oh I should be angry in those
situations too
he says but in a peculiar way of its own
for resentment itself as well as what is
done in consequence of it is the object
of resentment so you know you raise your
voice to me I don't like that I get
angry I raise my voice to you you get
angry at me you say why are you raising
your voice at me and We're Off to the
Races so to speak right
so I think he's quite right about this
he also says that there's another way in
which once we get into this Dynamic
there is a tendency to produce yet more
anger and he says that
um you know the first offense even when
so slight is presently to be dropped and
forgotten becomes the occasion of
entering into this whole dynamic in the
process of this strife and variance
people change Parts he who was at first
the injured person becomes the more
injurious and blameable than the
aggressor now why is that the case he
talks about the numberless personalities
which we all have for ourselves and this
leads to us thinking ourselves injured
when we're not or that the injury is
greater than it really is and he says if
bear retaliation are returning just the
mischief
received always begin begets resentment
in the person upon whom we retaliate
what would that excess do add to this
that he the other person likewise has
their partialities and so each of us has
a tendency to respond with more anger
than the anger that has been shown to us
so there's this tendency as he says to
magnify offenses and this leads to
there's a beautiful phrase a long
intercourse of ill offices doing bad
things to each other and it can go on
and on and on he says there's no
representing this scene of rage and
Madness it is Manifest there would be no
bounds nor any end since the Indulgence
of Revenge does have this tendency and
does actually produce these effects and
proportion as it is allowed then you
know we shouldn't indulge it right so
that that's one big problem this
tendency to provoke more anger he also
um says that anger and retaliation
should only be used used to produce a
greater good it was as he says placed in
human beings on supposition of and as a
prevention or remedy to irregularity and
Disorder so we don't want that passion
itself producing irregularity and
disorder and he says you know
if we consider humankind according to
that fine illusion of Saint Paul as one
body and everyone members of one another
then resentment is with respect to
society a painful remedy and he says
this is not founded on an illusion or
simile it's drawn from the very nature
of the passion itself and he actually
has a great example a little bit later
on about well what do we do with
criminals right what if we what if we
execute somebody and remember executions
were much more common back then than
they are in in our present day at least
in the developed countries and he says
that you know if if we're considering
executing a criminal you know we're
actually doing something bad to them and
that's very clear why would we do it
well uh the person's life is
inconsistent with the quiet and
happiness of the world that is a general
and more enlarged obligation destroys a
particular and more find one so you know
we should treat criminals well unless
they just can't be part of society so
that's that should play some
restrictions on retaliation as well and
then finally he's got this third
interesting argument about passions and
ends and he says listen we've got all
these different passions and desires and
affects they're part of our human nature
and what are they actually for what is
their purpose what do they do well each
of them has a particular end a purpose a
function you could say so think about
sexual desire right what is its purpose
I mean Butler I think would be fine for
saying the propagation of the species
can you do other things with sexual
desire like uh turn it in ways that
produce all sorts of pleasure absolutely
can it be used to Foster intimacy indeed
it can it could be used for all sorts of
things you could also use it to say make
money right you're interested in having
sex so you prostitute yourself now the
question that Butler is concerned with
is not simply what's the main purpose
what is the you know fundamental primary
purpose and what else can you do with it
it's whether
the other thing that you're doing with
it does it contradict the main purpose
if not he says well it's innocent so you
know if sexual pleasure does not get in
the way of propagating the species or at
least being open to that hey perfectly
fine right if it's definitely getting in
the way of it okay now you've got a
problem and we can think about this now
with respect to anger well what is the
the point of anger what is its purpose
and you know he does talk about you know
protecting society and self-defense and
all of these sorts of things but you
know how does anger actually
work he says that there's a difference
between this passion and all others no
other principle or passion has for its
end the misery of our fellow creatures
now does it is it just oriented at the
misery it's oriented at the misery as
retaliation that is viewed as in this
case a good thing rather than a bad
thing right
he says malice and revenge mediate or
meditates evil itself and to do mischief
to be the author of misery is the very
thing which gratifies the passion so
anger is different than the other
emotions passions desires drives that we
have it comes to aim directly at
suffering of the person who has angered
us as its proper design right other
vices eventually do Mischief this alone
aims at it as an end so that's another
reason why we shouldn't be indulging
anger except when it's you know serving
some sort of legitimate purpose anger
had better be serving the general
benevolence if it contradicts it as is
the case so easily well then we need to
um
put you know put some some hold on the
retaliation or Revenge that we're
looking for Motivated by resentment and
Malice so these are all issues with
retaliation which is what anger not only
aims at but it's integral to the very
emotion itself and Butler wants to raise
these so that we we you know it's not
that we shouldn't get angry whatsoever
but so that we can be very cognizant
about how far retaliation should go and
whether in many cases we should even
think about retaliation at all so in
many cases we would want to set it aside